[Music]
thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
live from Keith this evening just over
24 hours before the one year anniversary
of Russia's invasion of Ukraine
[Music]
[Applause]
some 200 000 people attend a stadium
event in Moscow as President Putin
rallies support for the war
freedom is at stake Biden spends his
final day in Europe meeting NATO leaders
plus I meet the seriously wounded
Ukrainian soldiers who want to return to
the front line
also coming up tonight on Sky News at 10
breaking news the police officer has
been shot in Oma in Northern Ireland
who traveled to Syria to join the
Islamic State group loses an appeal to
get her British citizenship reinstated
the country's largest Supermarket Tesco
becomes the latest to put a limit on
sales of its fruit and veg
and ambulance workers announced more
strikes as nurses begin their talks with
the government
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's in our
press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
good evening from kieving Ukraine it's
approaching one year since this country
was invaded by Russia and today in
Moscow 200 000 people gathered inside a
stadium for a rally and to hear from
President Putin the crowd at times were
chanting Russia and victory will be ours
while Putin hailed his soldiers fighting
in Ukraine but in Warsaw where NATO
members were meeting the U.S President
Joe Biden concluded his trip with a
message that it was Freedom that was at
stake
tonight we'll report from here in Kiev
and get the stories of the Ukrainian
soldiers injured in this war from vadal
north of Hamburg in Germany where we
hear from A supplier of parts for
leopard two tanks promised to Ukraine
but first this evening Diana magnet
reports from Moscow where 200 000 people
gathered for that rally
he walks into tumultuous Applause
they've been waiting a long time and it
is bitterly cold from the president a
rally and cry for their men at the front
and for Unity
thank you
Idiot Boy is
Gardens
hurray
[Applause]
people had been pouring in since morning
many from State companies even though it
was never officially confirmed the
president would show and just outside
the stadium the buses they came in on
row upon row of them it is extraordinary
that an event the president may or may
not attend and which we can't get
accreditation for even days before
manages to attract tens of thousands of
people hours before he's even rumored to
show up it really speaks to the power of
the state Machinery working away in the
background how do you feel about sort of
being told to come to an event that then
shown on State tv as a Great Patriotic
moment
um
[Music]
foreign
bikers club who's known to ride with
Putin
I wish you to get rid of the American
yolk he tells me
the U.S president was having a meeting
in Warsaw at that moment with countries
who'd shaken off the Soviet Yoke the
Bucharest nine they're called now NATO's
Eastern flank
thank you well in Moscow earlier in the
day Vladimir Putin had met with China's
top Diplomat Wang Yi at the end of his
European tour as questions swirl over
China's intentions and whether it might
move to support Russia militarily
back in the stadium extraordinary scenes
children the West would say were
abducted by Russia from the streets of
bombed out marihupal here described as
rescued the soldier who took them 367 in
all fated and these are touching scenes
it speaks to the way that both sides see
this terrible War through a glass Darkly
with little chance on either side that
sentiments will change
Donna McNay Sky News Moscow
well for months now Western allies of
Ukraine have agonized over the extent to
which they should arm the Ukrainian
forces but the decision to provide tanks
has raised questions about whether
countries have the military equipment to
give away one manufacturer which makes
parts for tanks in Germany has told Sky
News that he's worried that Germany's
military is already weakened our Europe
correspondent Siobhan Robbins reports
now from vadal north of Hamburg
in a sleepy Hamburg suburb a small
glimpse into Germany's War Machine this
plant makes parts for heavy weapons
including the in-demand leopard 2 tank
but while President Putin said he's
scaling up his arms production here they
warn Germany hasn't been doing the same
for me it is worrying that Germany is
donating protein leopards to tanks to
Ukraine and has not reordered a single
one Germany is one of the biggest donors
to Ukraine last year it also announced a
hundred billion Euro fund to boost its
own military but making weapons takes
time if I ordered a leper 2 tank today
how long before one could be delivered
it will last between 12 months and 24
months in the meantime it's feared
Germany's leaving itself exposed well
it's weakened on a daily level that is I
think clear
we have not only given away leopard two
tanks we also have given away the big
who with us we have given away German
Iris tea Rockets to the Ukraine air
defense
Army so we are bledding out if you still
want how serious is this for defense of
the country as long as the conflict
stays in the Ukraine
there is time but who can control that
for decades really since the end of the
Cold War Germany's military has
traditionally been underfunded and
Putin's Invasion has presented
authorities here with two big challenges
firstly they have to keep supplying
Ukraine but then there's also the
mammoth task of upgrading their own
military
the defense ministers pledged to invest
on both fronts and wants more cash for
arms a Ministry spokesman told me as
part of NATO Germany would never have to
defend itself solo but the war in
Ukraine is draining allies supplies too
the German Ministry of defense is
plainly wrong on this because yes
Germany is in NATO but in a way Germany
is NATO and NATO NATO's armed forces or
NATO's military strength is the strength
of its member states and so with member
states do not have the military forces
required that NATO NATO is weak
depleted before the war broke out
Germany's military is now in an even
worse shape an urgent problem requiring
urgent action
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Hamburg
well this war has of course claimed
countless lives of civilians in Ukraine
and thousands of dead and injured
fighters on both sides many troops in
Ukraine have lost limbs but a number of
specialist clinics across the country
are producing and fitting Prosthetics
it's claimed 60 percent of soldiers are
returning to the war effort I visited
one Clinic here in Kiev
is a council official turned volunteer
Soldier for whom this war has dealt a
cruel blow
dimitro was trying to rescue a fellow
soldier who trod on a mine when his
world exploded too his left leg blown
off he thought he may die
but in this clinic in Kiev he is here to
meet the man who will help give him his
life back
for 43 of his 68 years Vladimir federov
has been making molds and fitting
Prosthetics but never has he crafted as
many as he has these past few months but
it's sad that you are so busy
hold on
if there was no war there would be less
suffering he tells me but now we share
their suffering we're suffering with
them
he is part of Ukraine's hidden war
effort and for dimitro his latest
patient this is his first fitting
it has been a painful sacrifice but one
he says that is worth it
for me my motherland is like my family
he says and I want to protect my family
there is not a single day not a single
minute that I regret volunteering yes it
was dangerous but I will never regret my
decision
when he is able he wants to go back to
fight and his wife Natalia supports him
this is his decision she says someone
has to do it that is how it should be if
God needs him to go to war
the same for many of these men being
helped by this Clinic
under therapy working hard to get back
on the front line
as many already have they claim sixty
percent of amputee soldiers in Ukraine
are making it back
but the road to recovery is a long one
and dimitro is at the beginning of it
Natalia recording every tentative step
One More Story from this war of the
Suffering The Spirit and the sacrifice
Mark Austin Sky News
Keith
well U.N general assembly is uh meeting
in New York tonight our U.S
correspondent Mark Stone joins us from
there now and Mark President Biden
heading back to the States tonight uh
what do you think his visit has achieved
well I think there's no question that in
the White House they will be very
pleased with that visit not least did he
manage to get to Kiev itself an
extraordinary moment but that rousing
speech in Warsaw yesterday uh
demonstrated I think the Biden White
House will show a real Unity that has
not broken it's fractured at times but
it has been repaired through the course
of this year-long conflict Focus now
will shift here to New York uh to the
highest diplomatic body the the uh the
general the United Nations the general
assembly meeting has just got underway
some might see this as a talking shot
but look the fact is that the only place
that both sides the Russians and the
ukrainians are sitting in the same room
is here in New York that is progress
even if they have two entirely different
versions of reality that they are
showing the the Russians are are
presenting a an alternate version of
what has happened over the course of the
past year there'll be a UN General
assembly sorry security council meeting
on Friday that will be a key moment I
think I caught up a few moments ago with
Ukraine's foreign minister Dimitri
qadeba who is here in New York and one
of the questions that we asked him which
I think is critical to all of this is if
the West is to give you a fighter jets
as Ukraine wants what will they do with
them because the concern and the reason
that Western Nations do not want to give
fighter jets to Ukraine is that they
believe Ukraine will use them to strike
Russia itself and that that would create
a much much larger conflict he was quite
clear to me he said if we get fighter
jets and we want them we will use them
to fight and to to strike Russia within
the occupied territories of eastern
Ukraine But to answer your broader
question from Biden's perspective this
trip will have been a success a year
into this conflict
okay mark thank you very much indeed and
that is about it from Kiev for this
evening let's go back to Hannah in
London
mark thank you
a police officer has been shot in Omer
in Northern Ireland tonight it's
understood the officer had been coaching
a youth Gaelic football team at a sports
center let's get more than our Island
correspondent Stephen Murphy joins us
now so what do we know Stephen
fabrication getting underway by The
Police Service of Northern Ohio that the
one man is serving police officer was
rushed to hospital after being shot at a
sports complex in Oma just before eight
o'clock this evening reports from those
at the scene say that the officer was
involved in a coaching session at a
sports complex in Oma when he was
attacked and reportedly hit multiple
times in this attack he was taken to the
altner Galvin Area Hospital which is in
Derry or Londonderry we don't have
official confirmation of this condition
but it is understood to be serious now
condemnation has been Swift right across
the politicals back in shinseng Michelle
O'Neill the first Minister designate
here I was called it an outrageous and
shameful attack and she unreserveably
condemned what she called a
reprehensible attempt to murder a police
officer from the union aside Jeffrey
Donaldson and the leader of the dup uh
it said it was terrible news and it's
hard when okay to the family of the
courageous police officer these
terrorists he said have nothing to offer
and they must be brought to Justice and
it's interesting that Jeffrey Johnson
uses the word terrorist obviously at
this early stage it is too early to know
the motivation behind this attack but we
do know that it Bears all the Hallmarks
of dissident Republican groupings who
have been uh very open in their desire
to attack and to murder police officers
here in Northern Ireland you also have
to look at the timing of this incident
coming as it does among the heated
political discourse of the efforts to
obtain a Pro Sport deal like to try and
get the devolved government at Stormwind
back up and running so we do not know
yet if this is a terrorism incident but
if it is a proven to be of course a time
a dissident Republicans attack which
certainly many in the area expect that
it is uh it is another reminder as we
approach the 25th anniversary of the
Good Friday agreement I just how fragile
the piece here in Northern Ireland
remains
Stephen will await further details of
course thank you
the governor says it is pleased with the
decision by a court to reject member
begum's bid for citizenship begum who
run away from home in London when she
was 15 to join the Islamic State group
in Syria had her citizenship revoked by
the then Home Secretary Sergey Javed
back in 2019. her lawyers argued that
she was trafficked and groomed and said
this is not the end our home editor
Jason Farrell has this report
in a detention camp in Syria since 2019
shamima begum is stuck in this strange
indefinite Purgatory based on a decision
she made at the age of 15.
and a set of rulings in London the most
recent by the immigrations appeals
commission saying the Home Secretary had
every right to withdraw her citizenship
they implication the outcome that we
face is that no British child who has
been trafficked outside the UK
will be protected
by the British state if the Home
Secretary invokes National Security
her lawyers had argued that when begum
set out from bethnal green with two
friends to join Isis in Syria she was
effectively being groomed and trafficked
and that the government's own
counter-terrorism strategy identified
this problem
but the state says she went with her
eyes wide open to the horrors of this
group and remains a threat to National
Security and I think she has obviously
mounted a case through the courts and
she's lost it I'm I'm pleased the courts
have upheld our interpretation of the
nationality rules for for the country
that that she is also eligible to be a
citizen often I think that's the right
thing to do
judge Robert J said reasonable people
will differ as to the threat she posed
in February 2019 to the National
Security of the United Kingdom and as to
how that threat should be balanced
against all countervailing
considerations however under our
constitutional settlement these
sensitive issues are for the Secretary
of State to evaluate and not for the
commission
so essentially it's a political decision
but the UK is an outlier on this
most countries are now slowly bringing
back their women and their children and
France over 100 Germany over a hundred
so the UK is beginning to look a little
bit in an isolated position here
shamima begum hasn't yet responded to
the ruling when she first emerged From
the Ashes of the so-called Isis
caliphate she showed little remorse
I don't regret it because I it's changed
me as a person It's Made Me Stronger
tougher you know I married my husband I
wouldn't have found someone like him
back in the UK
but more recently she insists she should
be allowed to face Justice in the UK I
feel like the only crime I committed was
coming here so I would be willing to go
to prison for that but like for the
accusations made against me I'm just
gonna have to fight against them
shamima begum's lawyers say the fight
goes on but perhaps her best hope is for
a more sympathetic Home Secretary Jason
Farrell Sky News
Tesco and ALDI have become the latest
supermarkets to put limits on the sale
of some fruit and vegetables due to
supply shortages Britain's biggest
grower of tomatoes has told Sky News
that those shortages could continue
until the end of April or even early May
Skies Matthew Thompson reports
Choice our ancestors could only dream of
modern supermarkets have it all that is
until they don't across the country
fruit and veg Isles are increasingly
bare Tesco has joined Aldi Asda and
Morrisons in introducing rationing
I don't suppose you've noticed vegetable
shortages yeah massive yeah yeah just
now were you looking for them
particularly or tomatoes they're a bit
insipid this time of year
I think like everything else I just go
with the flow and see what happens you
know that's it
that's it pretty sanguine of you well
what else can we do babe
no Panic buying I would say as yet I
mean I've not walked in and been like
there is absolutely no food to be had
um it's just you know potentially buying
Alternatives or something different
shelves at this smaller grocer looked
healthier but not for long the owner
told us his wholesale costs have
recently doubled there are two main
reasons for the shortages first bad
weather in parts of southern Europe and
North Africa places like Spain Tunisia
Morocco which the UK relies heavily on
at this time of year for most of our
salad crops secondly The Soaring cost of
energy has meant producers right here in
the UK have sharply reduced their own
production
and it may get worse before it gets
better the UK's largest tomato grower
has worn disruption could last until May
this year what's happened we've grown
the last year's crop later to try and
recover some some value because whatever
has been squeezed on prices from Not
Just Energy but fertilizer labor
everything's gone up so we're going
later
um so we've started later and so instead
of starting end of March which would
probably more like the end of April into
May
in response that the national Farmers
Union conference the environment
secretary had this to say front page of
every newspaper is salad shortages Asda
rationing that will be I can't control
the weather in Spain either so uh that
went down badly in a room of farmers who
say energy subsidies would have
supported domestic production until that
starts to increase we're unlikely to see
the green shoots of recovery on our
shelves Matthew Thompson Sky News
ambulance workers are among NHS staff to
announce new strike action next month in
their dispute overpay but nurses held
talks with the government this afternoon
looking for a breakthrough that could
end their strike action well these are
the main plan strikes over the next few
weeks ambulance workers with the unite
Union in Wales and the northwest of
England are striking today and in
Northern Ireland over the next couple of
days teachers from four unions will
strike in Scotland and parts of England
on the 28th while University staff are
continuing strikes this week and next
there will be National strikes by
ambulance staff on the 6th and the 20th
of March and nurses paramedics blood
collection workers and other NHS staff
will take action on the 8th of March
University staff will hold more strikes
also in March and driving test examiners
will strike for 10 days across England
Scotland and Wales next month well the r
t Union has announced strike action on
the 16th 18th and 30th of March and
London Underground workers represented
by ASLA for strike on the 15th of March
Sky's Health correspondent Ashish Joshi
has this report
Simon is conflicted about the nurses
talking to the government
as a striking paramedic he believes
health workers should be United in their
fight for pay and working conditions it
makes us feel like second-class citizens
and the frustration and disappointment
and anger at the government's choice to
speak to the nurses
representatives and not to our unions
is really tangible now
the last time paramedics went out on
strike they stood shoulder to shoulder
with nurses on the picket line but in
the future they may not have asean
nurses alongside them
there are five unions representing
health workers in dispute with the
government but inside this building only
one of those unions is in talks with the
government the RCN now that's led to
some anger one of those other unions
Unison has said in a very strongly
worded statement that the government
can't afford to pick and mix Solutions
and that it risks making a bad situation
even worse but end that frustration was
echoed by the BMA whose Junior doctors
are set to announce the dates for their
strikes they've given the health
secretary until tomorrow to meet I
understand that he's a very busy man and
it's almost because like a Schoolboy
he's left all his homework until the
last minute he's got multiple disputes
now with multiple professions and we've
all come to the same moral calculation
nurses
physiotherapists doctors we have to take
strike action
the talks with the RCN are expected to
continue until the end of this week and
are likely to focus on next year's pay
rise
this year nurses and other NHS staff
below the grade of doctor were given an
average pay rise of 4.75 percent
for next year the government has
proposed an increase of 3.5 percent for
all NHS staff in Scotland the RCN has
recommended its members except a 6.5 pay
rise and in Wales nurses are being
balloted on a new pay deal that would
increase last year's backdated payoffer
by three percent
so while there is some optimism a
settlement can be reached with the RCN
other Healthcare unions are warning of a
broken NHS work one that is now divided
to
Ashish Josh is Sky News
lancashire's police and crime
commissioner has asked the College of
policing to carry out an independent
review Into the handling of the Nicola
bully case it comes after The
Independent office for police conduct
launched its own investigation into a
welfare check carried out by Lancashire
police on the 10th of January days
before Nikola disappeared
now tomorrow we'll see the publication
of a new government blueprint for how
men's football should be governed in
England in what has been described as
the biggest shake-up since the formation
of the Premier League back in 1992 well
since then the game has become a
multi-billion pound industry even as
clubs in the lower leagues face
financial hardship and even the threat
of going out of business our Sports
correspondent Rob Harris reports
come on this is football when fans feel
betrayed exploited and fearing for their
club's existence
West Bromwich Albion one of England's
first League clubs 135 years ago but now
with an owner who's burdened them with
loans
fans feeling helpless the biggest worry
as me as a fan is
Arona not selling the club not realizing
the club isn't worth what he paid for it
or what he thinks the club is worth
he doesn't sell and we end up in
administration and that is a reality
absolute reality
I chose him to say that but it is
and it's this anguish this helplessness
where the government is intervening just
like utilities and financial services
football is set to be the latest
industry with an independent regulator
imposed it's got to be a good thing for
English football but the regulator have
got to have teeth it's got to be able to
to make real change
changing who approves new owners
currently it's the role of the Premier
League and the English football league
but soon a football regulator could have
oversight of that vetting process to
avoid having owners who exploit clubs
and risk Financial ruin it's following
pressure from fans that the government's
stepping in and I want a bigger say in
the running of their clubs to protect
them
from decisions that led to this the
attempt by six teams to join a European
Super League without listening to
supporters this is really unprecedented
scenes No protests at Manchester United
and Beyond saw the Breakaway collapse
The Rage that's produced The Regulator
and what started out as a few is now in
number Rogue owners or owners who are
speculated as owners who perhaps the
egos carry them away or or who just want
to make a financial turn we need to do
everything we can to sort of stop that
stop stop those abuses I think a
regulator independence strong property
supported by the legislation should be
capable of doing that
however much resistance there's been
from football and the Premier League in
particular it's Parliament not the pitch
where the future of the national sport
is being shaped Rob Harris Sky News
Westminster